[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
38th
q and a edition for
i don't know mid august 2020. it's early
august 2020 still
i think it may qualify as ben it's very
late early august i think
it's only the beginning of the end yeah
it is that all right
let's just get right into it we've got a
couple of questions from episode 37
we've got uh one from earlier that i
kept on forgetting to go back to
and then we've got one from the discord
so i have told the find people at
discord who were interested in
in voting on questions i said we're not
going to do a voting system in general
but
um up to one um also the cat does not
get a vote no matter what
um but up to one one question
a week if they want to vote on uh we
will answer it here so we've got one
like that here so you guys can oh no you
get ears you can see the ears right okay
um there we go um
first question all right from episode 37
why
uh did consciousness and big brains
evolve in homo sapiens it would seem
that sapiens babies being useless for
years would have been an evolutionary
dead
end so i said last time wow that's a big
question this warrant's
whole lifetimes of research um but
i i did promise that we'd come back to
it and talk a little bit about it
uh and you're looking at me like you got
it
you got it in five words or less you can
name that
answer in five words yeah i think we can
do this i mean you know it synonymizes
well it doesn't synonymize but it
combines consciousness and big brains
and i think we know the answer for
disproportionately big brains which
comes from
so i'm borrowing from dick alexander
my phd advisor who argued
that there was an arms race between
human populations that there's a point
called ecological dominance at which
human beings become
the most important hostile force for
other human beings and at that point
thinking about what competitor groups
are going to do
counteracting it with your own clever
strategies becomes the way to get ahead
and so basically human against human
population level
conflict resulted in an arms race that
enlarged our brains so we could out
think each other
and i would argue that consciousness
fits that model that consciousness is a
tool
deployed for novelty and
that basically in order to out-think
your
human competitor's consciousness and
therefore collective
engagement on abstract questions was the
key tool
okay so i'm going to add two things here
i'm just going to clarify one thing you
said which is you use the term hostile
forces
which is a reference to darwin's term
hostile forces
where he was imagining i think he split
it into biotic and abiotic although
maybe that's a later
uh addition he was looking at the
hostile forces that individuals and
species were having to deal with
and seeing things like weather and
climate and
predators and competitors and pathogens
and
uh and parasites and seeing that these
were the selective forces
uh that species were evolving uh you
know basically away from
it or enabling themselves to be able to
respond to
and dick alexander's one of dick
alexander's many remarkable
contributions to understanding of human
evolution was to see
uh impart uh humans as
our own most significant hostile force
in human evolution so that's that's one
point just slightly clarifying uh for
those who didn't know
you know who might have imagined that
you were just saying hostile forces
because it seemed like the right words
i think they are the right words but
this is a literally a darwinian term
and then i would also say to the second
part of this question and it's all
wrapped up together
it would seem that homo sapiens babies
being useless for years would have been
an evolutionary dead end
um this this gets at the question of
effectively why why parental care you
know why
on a a continuum of ways to reproduce
would you ever go away from i'm just
going to have as
many kids as possible but because that
means that they're
way more than i a parent could ever
engage with
i'm never going to probably meet any of
them so lots and lots of kids totally
anonymous to the parents
all the way to what we see in humans and
some other species
where you have very few children at a
time and every one of them is precious
and you invest
remarkably in them as you move um you
know the
one of the ways that some of you will be
familiar with this has been called is
um excuse me r versus k selection but as
you move
over towards that sort of human dolphin
wolf other great apes uh
um elephant end of the spectrum uh you
also
end up with not just more and more
parental care but more and more uh
altricial children so we all know the
word precocious
you know a kid who seems to be able to
speak in full sentences before you're
expecting them to
it's not exactly the same word but a
precocial
infant in a species is one that can like
a giraffe
walk around and run within hours of
being born
at the other end of the spectrum is an
altruistic
baby one who is helpless for a
relatively long time well what does
altruciality get you beyond being
sitting meat for a would-be predator it
gives
it basically mandates lots and lots of
time with parents during which there's
going to be learning and so
consciousness
big brains plasticity brain plasticity
neuroplasticity behavioral plasticity
long childhoods mandatory parental care
all of these are of of a type and they
all contribute to
us being the remarkable beings that we
are or another way to say it
is that alteratiality is the unavoidable
downside of something
so good that it outweighs the
disadvantage that you point to which is
real
yeah okay the next question
uh came up last time as well asking if
we'd read the revolutionary phenotype we
said we hadn't
uh and the author has since reached out
to us and offered to send us a copy so
it
looks like a big long book i don't know
when we'll get to it but we will
at some point we'll come back to that
okay
this one from a couple of episodes ago
is a long question i'm just going to
summarize and just see if we want to
riff
um a little bit on this so this is um
this is
someone who um
i can't actually remember if i'm allowed
to to read it directly so
because i don't remember i'm going to
summarize and try to change some of the
details
here's a here's a guy i think um in a
in a relationship that he's been in for
a year with a girlfriend
uh she he had coveted she cared for him
uh she has you know they've had they've
been very close their lease is about to
be up and they're thinking about moving
in together and it sort of looks like it
might turn into
a you know the serious long-term
relationship they might even have kids
together
but you know he says she's caring and
loving
um but he says and here i will quote
she's very leftist and doubles down and
fortifies her arguments when presented
with grievance studies affair anything
idw peterson or even jonathan height
shuts down becomes hostile in the wake
of any credible evidence
watches view videos and somehow finds an
entire book about how the idw are evil
neo-right-wingers and considers that
giving it a chance
considers that to be sufficiently giving
it a chance unbiased research so
basically he's saying
what do i do do i do i need to leave
this relationship
um he also adds later um
that they're both people of color but
he's got some white in them and
she's never done it but he's afraid that
if they had kids together it would
actually
this would this would start getting
crowded out in an argument these sorts
of you know
you know most fundamental racial
differences so what to do
well i mean seems to me one of two
things
is very likely going on one is
that this is a very dire indicator of
some kind of
failure that there is
in the relationship we're in the human
being well in the person's thinking
that to the extent of the girlfriend
yeah to the extent
that uh i mean you know we've been
dismissed as right-wingers
you know since before idw was a thing
right
the problem is it doesn't withstand
scrutiny of the evidence
right and so it's one thing for a person
to have this mistake and impression
it's another thing for them to retain
the mistaken impression when confronted
with the ample evidence that for example
idw has many left-wingers in fact i
would argue it's more left-wingers than
right-wingers
right that is relatively easy to
demonstrate
and somebody who doesn't change their
position in the face of evidence i mean
there
could be other objections but you should
drop that one and if you don't drop that
one it's because there's something about
you
that's holding on to it maybe though
then maybe maybe what we could offer
is and you know without knowing either
these people maybe it's impossible but
you know how
how could he have that conversation like
how could he approach such a
conversation it may be that when she
comes at him
like this he has the sense of like i am
not allowed to speak i don't know how to
engage this
i'm expected to be silent here because
she's making this point that i'm not
allowed to object to like what
what could be done to even just open up
the possibility of
of a of a two-way channel as opposed to
what sounds like
him receiving this and feeling like oh
my god what have i gotten myself into
except she's so wonderful in these other
regards
well so that was what i was gonna say
about the other possibility
okay the other possibility is that this
is not a failure of her
cognitive model it's a failure in social
space where the cost of admitting that
you're listening to idw stuff in some
circles
is so high that there are people and i'm
now hearing a lot of these stories of
people who
know better but are holding to some
position because they don't know where
else to go
and you know in fact
we are now receiving troubling
indications that people who have
retained their mental clarity are now
finding that their social circle is
overwhelming them with this woke stuff
and you know people who were
clear-headed are losing their
their clear-headedness and so look
your romantic relationship your
permanent one
is the most important decision you will
ever make
and it is important
that it be built out of something sound
and what i would say
is if your girlfriend is suffering from
fear of what her social group will make
of
her awareness or openness to hearing idw
or whatever
whatever stuff it might be then you need
to create
a place in your relationship where you
can be honest with each other
and it doesn't put her in a bind when
she talks to other people she may not be
able to solve
her social bind and she may not be
prepared to
walk away from people she values who are
confused
or broken on this issue so
you know the ability when you close the
door of your house to
talk about what's really going on even
if you can't you know i mean look this
has happened in every one of these
tragic situations
it's the reason that you know the stasi
and the soviets you know did so much
spying on their own population
is that people very frequently knew what
was going on and even if in public they
maintained their discipline and talking
about the
parties that were oppressing them in
private they spoke about the truth
and it seems to me that that is
necessary and so
you need to have a space where you can
converse honestly
where you you can't no matter how much
of an introvert and how self-sufficient
you are
uh and i can i i count myself pretty
strongly in both of those things you
need to have
at least one and preferably more but at
least one person
to whom you can speak totally honestly
about what it is that you think might be
going on
and not fear reprisal in the outside
world as a result
yeah not fear being outed in a social
environment so if it were me i'd
probably say
you know look honey what you're saying
doesn't add up and i'm i'm concerned
that the reason that you would say
something that doesn't add up
is because this is a very frightening
moment and people have
gotten really aggressive about this
stuff but let's talk about what
really is true and then talk about the
predicament that knowing what's really
true puts you in
in the outside world i don't know i
don't know
if she can hear that but if that's
what's going on it's it's at least a
strong possibility that
um she will register it yeah
all right next question this this from
the discord
how uh trigger warning no
um this uses a word that i didn't know
so i had to look it up so as i read it
if you see if you hear a word you don't
know don't worry we'll define it
how does the discrepancy between
biological and cultural sexual maturity
lead to harmful paraphilias
such as ephebophilia how can we use
evolutionary theory to square this
equation and reduce the harm to our
society's youth
so ephemophilia being the particular
type of paraphilia like you know
particular kind of attraction
that is defined as being attracted to
sort of mid to late adolescence
so how does the discrepancy mean
biological and cultural sexual maturity
um lead to to such a thing and i how i
read this
question is um at the moment
we have uh men and women
who we have 18 to 25 year olds
who inhabit the bodies of adults but
often are not yet adults so they
cultural sexual maturity lags behind
biological sexual maturity
uh and this is uh potentially dangerous
yeah i'm not even sure i would put it
that way i think
there is a question about so we have
talked
frequently about the fact that men have
two reproductive strategies
one of those strategies is what one of
my students
labeled so and go so in go
is just purely a matter of delivering a
gamete and
not taking responsibility for the
consequences this is a bargain
for men evolutionarily speaking it also
is not likely to be
historically to have been a very common
successful mode
outside of rape where men force the
situation and war
now war which includes outside of
extreme situations
yeah right so in normal functioning
societies
um women are selected not to
reproduce with men who won't commit
because the cost of raising offspring is
so high
that um the fact that women are the
limiting sex that they deliver something
of high value in this regard means they
are in a good bargaining position to
demand
commitment etc but because reproducing
without commitment is such
a bargain for men evolutionarily
men cannot resist the implication that
it might be possible
and so what we have is this coupled with
the fact that birth control
now makes it possible for women to
engage in sex without nearly so much
danger of ending up with a baby that
they can't raise
um these things have combined to lower
the bar to having sex and that
has resulted in new mores arising
with respect to who one is allowed to
have sex with
and the problem is that basically the
rules as we now have them
are well if woman can sense then it's
okay
if she's above the age of consent and
she can sense well then
you know that's her business whereas in
a prior
circumstance there would have been an
understanding that many pairings
just are predatory from the point of
view of you know
men taking advantage maybe this is the
point you're making is that
um that young women who do not yet have
the maturity
to actually understand why they are
commanding so much attention
what its meaning is to you know to suss
out that they're being lied to by men
who want to lead them to believe
something is going on that isn't
but basically to me the way i read this
is exactly
at the heart of that you know you didn't
you never had the experience of coming
of age female
true for which
for which i am quite grateful e3
and i will say that um
you know everyone within a certain
certain distance of societal beauty
norms
uh who comes of age uh
at least until the last i don't know
what it's going to be 10 or 20 years
maybe um has this experience that at one
level feels very sudden
you go from child and you still feel
like a child and now you are just the
object of so much
attention and you cannot escape it and
this is this is the real part of what
the male gaze is right you cannot escape
it
and when you are fully embodied and
in your own self and you're out there
engaging with this
and you know if you're lucky and smart
you have to be both and you
avoid having any really bad interactions
with you know actual predators which
most of the people most of them men
looking at young women are not predators
by a large
degree but you learn to figure out the
difference
by being out there and experiencing it a
lot
right and i'm not saying that that is
wonderful in any way but you do
learn to figure out how to navigate and
especially because of all the sort of
infantilization that is happening
and because so much of the sexual
activity is happening behind screens
you have you have this just you know
constant display
of the you know fully new biosexualized
bodies
of young women who think that that is
where their worth comes from
and they all they get are the comments
back which are some combination
of you know repugnant and disgusting and
apparently congratulatory but
they're not real and it's really hard to
tell one anonymous account from another
in terms of like
what who are these guys and how do i
tell the difference
well and you know the other thing to say
is
i think on the female side we are
completely failing to convey something
that one's
uh older female relatives would once
have conveyed very clearly which is that
men and women or no men looking for
women
for sex and men looking for women for
partnership
are in very different states of mind men
ought to have a very low bar
evolutionarily speaking men ought to
have a very low bar
for desirability for some to have sex
with somebody and a very high bar
for wanting to partner with somebody to
raise a family and so in that second
phase men are very much like women they
don't have the same
set of priorities but they have very
high standards they're very
choosy in this other phase they may be
very so if you're a female and you don't
understand
that attracting male sexual attention is
not one thing it's two different things
then the point is and one of them takes
nothing and it actually potentially puts
you in harm's way
right in fact we know beauty counts a
lot but youth counts a lot too and so
women come online sexually they discover
oh my god
there's i have all of this power i can
detect that i can screw up a room full
of people by
you know my behavior so a
tragically that may be the height
of power that most women experience
in their life is the sexual power that
comes from
the youth and the fact that in ancestral
circumstances that was just simply a
measure of how many offspring they were
likely to be able to produce in a
lifetime
and it uh if you prioritize maximizing
that power
which inherently comes when you're young
it will get in the way of you learning
the things that you need
in order to actually have more
interesting kinds of power over which
you have some control
and for which you would deserve some
credit exactly
the problem though is that because
civilization is
constructed so poorly a woman who
foregoes
the exercise of that purely sexual
youth-based power
is not necessarily in a situation to
accumulate
the kinds of skills and knowledge and
insight that would
cause her to have more power later in
life when it was about something
that she had brought to the world right
so anyway we've got this tragic
situation we don't tell women look
if you're interested in men that the
kind of attention you will get
from uh flashing your boobs or whatever
is real but it's not it doesn't
translate into you will find a mate who
is
worthy of you and uh and all of that so
we don't
convey that lesson and we we arm women
poorly
we simply teach you know to the degree
that that's taught it's simply taught as
be modest right like have modesty
without identifying that there's really
that like male attention as you
as you just said is not one thing yeah
it's not one thing and the trivial
version isn't really worth
attracting it's too easy to attract and
it doesn't translate into anything
right so anyway what i would say is
in a world in which there is just power
there's a reason that men
are focused on young women especially
when it's in the phase
about women that they're not going to
continue to care about which has to do
with fertility pure and simple
and so it is not the same thing the fact
that
uh men of all ages in that phase
in that mental state are interested in
very young women
is a problem civilization should not be
encouraging that
and to the extent that we are
encouraging that it's not surprising
that we have
deranged the sexual landscape and
created a lot of stuff that
may not be illegal but is certainly
predatory in the sense of
you know it's men taking advantage of
women who don't know better
next question totally different topic
hypothesis on kovid risk cholesterol
and other sterols are foundational to
d-group vitamins
hormones cellular structure i'm not sure
exactly what the relationship is there
common statins lower total ldl
interfering with normal function without
addressing damaged and oxidized
ldl thoughts
i feel like there's a connection i don't
know what statins are
i think doing this is off the top
okay i believe there's some evidence
that statins are actually increasing
covered risk
so that's the thing that that has to be
true for this to track for me for this
question to track so i think i recall
reading that somewhere a month or so ago
i hope it wasn't something we said here
which guess i've totally forgotten
right well yeah so be it um but in any
case i think this is a
mechanistic hypothesis for why that
would be the case
akin to the um why do uh
proton pump inhibitors increase covet
from our last q a
yeah so what if if if that's right if
the missing piece
uh in the question is that statins use
of statins
is associated with an increased risk of
either contracting
or a degree of of
disease the badness of the disease
of covid uh what do we think of the
hypothesis
i mean i guess potential
i just don't know i don't remember
enough about the molecular biology to
totally assess it at first pass
it looks reasonable like each of these
seem like causal lengths that are
plausible
well i'll tell you um if this were class
i would tell you
yeah the next thing you need to do is
figure out what the prediction is of
this hypothesis that distinguishes it
from
other potential explanations and so i'd
be very curious if there is a unique
well for instance like are there other
common drugs that are given to lower
total ldl
such that um you know if statins do this
and this is
um and the missing piece of the puzzle
that we've identified is correct
um the prediction would be that those
other drugs that also lower total
ldl would have the same effect and that
they would also be associated with
a higher risk of covin so that's one
that would be one prediction or
conditions
that lower ldl without a drug oh good
yeah
yeah yeah next question
hawaii has instated a new emergency
order on oahu
all beaches parks and trails are closed
as outside is safer do you guys think
the purpose of this is more to
discourage tourists the 14-day
quarantine for visitors is mostly
ignored
well that's a good hypothesis
yeah the other hypothesis is that this
comes from the same confusion that
people seem to have
where they're almost mistaking a
signaling function um for
an epidemiological intervention like
look at me i'm careful i'm wearing a
mask even though i'm outside
alone yeah we're serious about covered
bad stuff is going to happen we're
serious about
you can tell we're serious because yeah
yeah so i hate that this is going on but
we see it every time
we go out we run into people i mean i
got that i got the side eye today i was
out walking in a park
um alone and someone
uh someone walked by in a mask it was
just the two of us in the park
and she glared at me i wasn't wearing a
mask of course i wasn't
right like for god's sake you need to i
didn't need to
and i'm not who she thinks i am and i
wasn't wearing my star or i was and that
you know like
all of this is has become so
tribal yeah tribal and
we are foregoing opportunities that we
need to avail ourselves of because at
the moment
outside is so hospitable um but i was
going to say the last time we went
kayaking
two guys walking down a beach
um wearing masks you know more than six
feet apart the two guys are
scampering or bouldering yeah
wearing masks you know it's not only are
they outdoors there's a breeze
there's the sun is shining and i mean
unless they lived right there they
probably
got there in the same car i mean maybe
they were masks in the car but you know
it's possible they were protecting
themselves from each other is my point
if if not that though there was no
reason
i agree but i i don't think they needed
to to protect themselves from each other
yeah on the beach
so the point is look you've got some
kind of a budget
you've got some kind of a level of
tolerance and you know one of the
reasons the us seems to be screwing up
the covet response so badly
is that we have a low tolerance for um
being told what to do especially being
told what to do on mass
that the individualism which is so much
a part of the magic of the place
is our achilles heel when it comes to
epidemiological stuff where
you know frankly wearing a mask isn't
that bad especially like to go into a
shop
it kind of sucks i'm not saying it's
good but i'm saying
as you know it's far short of gulag
you know it is i mean i was i mean you
and i i i hate it
i hate wearing my mask and i wear it i
mean we're now mandated to but i was
wearing it
in grocery stores hardware stores before
it was mandated
um because it was clearly the right
thing to be doing but i hate it and as
soon as i'm clear of
their the hvac you know not as soon as i
walk out the door but as soon as i'm
clear of anything that feels like it's
blowing stuff out from the store
i take it off sooner than than most
people do
well but look this is in part
a failure of the market we should be
delivering something that does the job
that doesn't have this impact and in
fact i was going to propose
winter is coming um what we need are
scarves that work
imagine that this came down to a scarf
that you wrapped around your face and
everybody understood that that was
functional and that it was constructed
of the sorts of materials that would do
this job effectively and then the point
is
suddenly this isn't a mask right
but interesting we need to be doing
something like that
you know i'm watching all of these
people wearing you know their mask
under their chin when they don't have it
on and it's just like it's not
comfortable it looks crazy
and you know we just don't have infinite
tolerance for that stuff so what we need
is something
that we do have infinite tolerance for
and in the meantime we need to take
advantage of
the period of time we're not threatened
you know by taking the thing
off and feeling like okay good you know
i i guarantee you professional skiers
do not go to bed with their ski boots on
you know they take them off
and that allows them to tolerate the
boots you know when they're working but
wouldn't it be safer if they were ready
to ski at any moment
slightly you never know but
but anyway yeah we should be we should
be borrowing
so that we can spend on it when we have
to yeah
okay another uh covered question between
mild and asymptomatic cases
and newly discovered t cell immunity i
don't know about this
is is spread wider than we thought and
close to burning out before a vaccine is
necessary
cases are declining in texas florida and
arizona
former hot spots such as new york city
sweden pakistan and italy seem to have
heard immunity
so there's a couple claims in here that
i just don't know about i don't know
about
newly discovered t-cell immunity or that
cases are declining in those three
states
um i would since you you know more
mostly i i will
let you answer this primarily but i will
say the concept of hurt immunity is a
is a dangerous one um we we know the
tests
suck so we really don't know who has
been exposed that didn't test positive
at the time and even if you didn't test
positive at the time if you hadn't you
just
there's no way to doubt it but um
the antibody tests are terrible as well
um
but herd immunity is a concept that
makes terrific
sense if your model is did you die or do
not
and as we've said over and over again
there's there are so many
growing concerns about um
serious symptoms systems that are
harmed even after you've survived covet
and of course we have no idea what the
actual long-term damage might be
yeah and i feel quite certain
that i do not feel certain we will be
able to detect this on the basis of how
crummy our data is on who actually had
this thing
but i feel quite certain that given the
massive damage that seems to accompany
these cases
in many ways even people who didn't have
symptoms seem to
risk
brain damage and heart damage yeah
this is going to knock years maybe
decades off people's lives
yep and we are not tracking that well so
what i would say is
it is possible that
herd immunity has some utility here and
that we would you know your question is
will we get there before a vaccine is
necessary
possibly however we will get there at
what cost
if some large fraction of the population
has had this disease and is going to
have chronic health conditions for the
rest of their lives and live
shorter lives as a result then what a
terrible price for
herd immunity so um
not sure but it's certainly not
something we should bank on
indeed
huge generational divide in the
democratic party where i live it wasn't
woke social issues it was medicare
young want it old have it already
would you have wendell potter on this is
the next part of this question i don't
know who wendell potter is
um oh the question continues
he's a former vp of cigna health now a
whistleblower
sounds like an interesting guest yeah um
so this is a
more of a more of a comment although
it's
it is telling that i don't know where
the person who's writing
lives um but that it was medicare that
split the democratic party and
you know this may be an aspect of this
that we haven't been talking about that
it seems like it's woke
that is that is going to be splitting
the democrats
and is so polarizing people away from
the democrats but that there are going
to be splinter issues all over the place
that are
different it's basically becoming what
you know maybe it was always true
but it felt in the 90s uh
like the republicans were a collection
of special interest groups that didn't
really have a lot to do with one another
you know what what were the
two-way enthusiasts doing with the white
evangelical christians inherently you
know what was the connection there
but increasingly clearly the democrats
are are this
a bunch of special interest groups that
are that are together and
unfortunately seeming to try to unite
under this sort of intersectional
woke flag it's a natural outgrowth
of the abandonment of uh basically
wages and protections for workers as the
signature issue yep
thanks for being a beacon of
enlightenment and dark times
do you think mankind view ourselves and
our race in a sufficiently evolutionary
context
is it possible that our perception of
reality is far less accurate than we
believe
um well i want to completely understand
that
do you think mankind view ourselves in
our race
internet no um
what we do is we have a distortion
that has been adaptive in past
circumstances
that distortion was never accurate and
in fact i've argued that
self is itself a distortion built to get
you to behave in ways that are adaptive
for something
that one would call lineage the problem
is
that our distortion which is adaptive is
built for an environment we don't live
in
so it's out of place and distorted
which makes it very difficult for us to
figure out what
we should have which would either be a
new distortion
that worked for our modern environment
or an undistorted view
that would allow us to correct for
whatever errors
through analytically understanding them
and we have neither so basically
we are involved in an infinite cycle of
self-harm
that um is uh pretty needless
but this is part of a big part of what
we're trying to address in the book that
we're writing
right um provide uh sufficient
access to the evolutionary toolkit such
that you can
individuals can begin to assess the
hyper novel situation that we're in and
make decisions
uh that thread the needle between
harkening back to traditional solutions
that continue to work
and looking for better solutions that
have not been imagined before
absolutely
pooled batch group those are all
alternative synonyms i think pooled
batch and group pcr testing
could cheaply and frequently test
everyone in developed countries
can you please validate and magnify this
idea among your media and elite media
circles
so i don't know what it means to test
everybody you could see
whether or not there was anybody in a
group that was
uh infected and then you need to you
know
start punching it down right yep um and
yeah i guess
it will work
depending on what the background rate of
infection is or
of pass infection is um
you would need different sizes of
initial groups to maximize the
efficacy and the efficiency of this
um because well i won't go into the math
but
yeah you know it would require a lot of
tinkering but i absolutely agree that
um i guess i haven't heard it called all
those things but pooled pcr testing
uh where you collect whatever it's
usually
saliva right sometimes blood um
um or is pcr always blood no no then
i had no pcrs is i had a nasal swab
nasal swell okay so
mucosal membrane stuff um
yeah you collect from you know hundreds
of people at a time and just do
one test um this it could cheaply and
frequently test everyone
the questions again and still and always
is how reliable is the test
so this would be a way of getting more
people tested faster
and anytime you had a positive you'd
have to go in and you know split a group
of 2000 into 10 groups of uh 200 and
you know sorted out that way but um it
still requires that the testing is
actually
hyper accurate and we just don't i see
no evidence of it being so
yeah i mean the number of anecdotes
every day i hear more anecdotes
from people i know and people i only
know online but like
saying yep my doctor declared me an
official false negative
visual false negative yeah the hell so i
think uh
i would have to look into whether or not
it actually was the case but i have the
sense that this is
um a case of massive market failure
where you know a a public effort to
produce tests might have produced
something
you're talking about not the failure not
the failure to pool pcr testing but the
failure
of the test themselves the low quality
of the tests
is a result i think of many private
efforts to generate a test
that were saleable because there wasn't
anything much better
and yes i don't know what would have
happened if a much better test
had emerged would it have succeeded
uh competitively but at some level
this didn't work and
it you know unless there's some reason
that you couldn't make a good test
uh this was the biggest failure of all
because it just blinded you at every
level you couldn't
tell what damage there was you couldn't
tell how it spread because you just
didn't have good data on who didn't who
didn't have it nope there are no there
there can no there can not be good data
now yeah from earlier there could be
good data going forward at some point
presumably
love the show just bought the de cameron
thanks for expanding my reading list
you're welcome senor saboya it's mr
onion
are certain values such as individual
freedoms or collective security
inherent to the system conserving right
inherit to the system conserving right
and the change focused left
can these values reverse in different
contexts such as the ussr versus the us
or historically
yeah i think this is why we're having a
debate or at least we're having a debate
about classical liberals who are
conservative
which is that these things were uh once
liberal values they
they succeeded and now conservatives are
defending them
so yes we have a confusion between
our relative terms about which direction
we should go in our absolute terms about
values but yes they can reverse this
does confound me like
i think anyone with any sense of history
understands that for instance
parties come to change what they stand
for over time right
but the idea that left versus right you
know having
you know being more focused on the
individual
individual rights and freedom versus
being more focused
on making sure that everyone in a
society has
some human rights and being more focused
perhaps on justice
but in both cases understanding that the
freedom loving people on
the right and the justice loving people
on the left recognize that there are
trade-offs and that there's no one on
the right who doesn't also understand
the value of justice nor is there anyone
who is on the left doesn't also
understand the value of freedom
that those those seemed stable to me
but even that seems to be increasingly
muddled well it does make conversation
increasingly difficult as well i'm
wondering if this isn't the
thing we were wrestling with in the the
first hour
where it seems that these even these
things are being lost
because actually we're now having a
conversation without content
yeah um yeah maybe that's it yeah
another request to invite a guest neil
howe author of the first fourth turning
on your podcast would love to know his
thoughts on unity 2020 and how to save
the republic
do you know this name uh i know the
fourth turning
uh so presumably i do know him as the
author
uh this is a generational model for
change
okay so i'll just put both of these
suggestions in yellow for us to return
to
great are cosmetics an extended human
phenotype
women often use cosmetics to increase
their attractiveness to men
historically how do cosmetics for men
fit in here like war paint or
face paint interesting question so just
to frame it
the reference to an extended human
phenotype is a reference to an idea
first posited by dawkins in a book of
the same name
82 maybe it was a second book early 80s
called the extended phenotype
uh in which he argued uh that for
instance the dam of a beaver
is part of its extended phenotype that
is uh no
less the product of or you know
beaverish stuff than
the fur on the beaver or its heart um
and it was an it was an extension of the
model of how to understand the products
of evolution
so our cosmetics and extended human
phenotype in that model for sure
i wouldn't say for sure really yeah okay
because the implication of extended
phenotype
is that the genes are causing this
alteration
in the world and so you know oh i guess
okay so since you stricto dawkins
extended fian type sensu stricto not so
much
since ulato yeah so um you know i mean
the argument that dawkins and i
had yeah several octobers ago in chicago
was i argued that religion was extended
phenotype in other words that the genes
set this thing
in motion and that it was advancing
their interests which he didn't
agree with but um cosmetics
could be that and they are certainly
related in the sense that
females are human females are the
ornamented sex and that that is
true physiologically but it's also true
at the level of adornment
you know um so uh with the exception of
things like war paint
right like when we we see men um
decorating themselves
in times of celebration in times of war
yeah yeah
but the question is well and actually
and with with things not on their bodies
with ornaments like cars yeah the the
question in this case
though is there's some tendency
there physiologically females are
ornamented
there's a tendency to behaviorally yeah
anatomically there's a tendency to
augment that
a cultural tendency a long-standing
cultural tendency to augment that across
many cultures
right and then there's um you know maybe
she's born with it maybe it's maybelline
[ __ ] which is really an economic
factor in which
the thing isn't driven by uh the women
necessarily it's
in large measure driven by the profit
motive
of yeah people so often aren't women so
is it adaptive
uh to be deceptive in this way yes does
that make an extended phenotype no
and is it if it's adaptive only because
your competitors are doing
it and so you don't have a choice you
know that puts it in
its own category it's sort of it's i
mean it's it's fishery and
run away it's wrong sexual selection
yeah exactly without necessarily being
extended phenotype okay yeah i i buy it
i stand corrected
i sit correct yes i'll stand later and
then i'll be corrected
what is the purpose of language like
people with periods or
pregnant people why does this
inclusiveness make me so angry
why is gender identity not provable and
affects less than one percent replacing
sex yeah you're not alone you're not
alone
you're being gaslit yeah you're being
gaslit i will say um
i don't know where all we're gonna go
but i um
abigail schreier who wrote the recent
book and i can't remember the name of it
i should i'll i'll show it next time
we're on
um about the rapid onset gender
dysphoria that seems to be happening to
teenage girls specifically
um as a as a contagion in teenage girls
she and i have just begun a a letter
wiki exchange
about what is happening specifically
over um you know the focus she she
made the initial missive in in letter
wiki
um about what's happening to teenage
girls and and
what we can attribute these this these
contagions
to um with regard to like comparing them
to comparing
human females to non-human primates and
you know what what friendships among
non-human primate females have looked
like
the question more broadly of
why gender identity is replacing sex
is exactly i think that's spot on in
terms of
the question that um why do we even call
it why do we call it gender dysphoria
this isn't gender dysphoria gender is
the behavioral manifestation of sex
in every other species gender exists
outside of humans it absolutely does
people who tell you it's a human
creation no they're wrong we call it sex
role
and it is the behavioral manifestation
that is typical for the sex that you
were born to
so gender dysphoria that's just like
being a tomboy
but that's not what gender dysphoria
especially is understood by
uh you know by the psychological
therapeutic manuals
is understanding to be what what they
really mean is
sex dysphoria and calling it gender
dysphoria is part of the confusion
now add to that people with periods and
pregnant people
and yeah this is this is gaslighting and
it's regressive
and it's misogynistic and it's nasty
and it all comes in this cloak of aren't
we loving and inclusive and no you're
not
so why does it make you so angry it's
because you're being manipulated and
you're being manipulated
by a threat and the problem is you know
um megan murphy is no longer on twitter
because she insisted that men weren't
women right
how dare she that's a measure of threat
and the idea of well
certainly you're supportive of trans
people yes
well if you're supportive of trans
people then you're supportive of
trans women competing in women's sports
no ah transphobe okay certainly you're
supportive of a black lives matter
well i know that black lives do matter
well then you're supportive of
abolishing the nuclear family aren't you
right no exactly so at some level
the idea that um some men have periods
for example
this is designed to out you it's
designed to get you
to either submit or to say something
that will allow you to be
stigmatized and the point is you don't
have a choice outside of those so of
course
you're angry to be asked a question
where those are your two options
you're damned if you do and damned if
you don't um yeah it's an attempt to
categorize and stigmatize
well the point is look i don't care
which thing you say right
some men have periods right you know and
then it's like well
no ah failure mode a yes um
join the club um so
okay heads i win tales you lose has
never been a very good game
and this is that and so really getting
at is
we are at the conversation that has no
content
right what what is the claim that some
men have periods
except for a delineator of whether
you are going to submit or
be hunted as a witch that's that's its
purpose is to get you to declare a side
its purpose is not to assert something
factual which was is what it sounds like
it is it's a factual claim that isn't a
factual claim
so that that's all true and that may be
the most
that's at least one of the most
important pieces of it um but it is
having ramifications
in the real world on our young people
that is going to create um a significant
fraction of a whole generation that is
going to be
extraordinarily damaged i saw uh i saw a
picture
in the last week of someone at some
protest presumably
you know one of the protests that's
happening right now that is you know
supposedly about
police brutality and black lives matter
and all of this the signs said
puberty is optional
puberty is optional no it's not
yeah these people are so wrong they are
so confused i don't think the person
holding that sign was
intentionally gaslighting anyone they
had been gaslit themselves
and they are unable to tell reality from
i don't even know what a unicorn yeah
well
um the the problem is this is all
uh part of a plan that involves
de-individuating you distancing you from
your family unless they're willing to
come along
and be part of the revolution yeah and
it
moves through schools there was a very
interesting
disturbing thread you can find it on
benjamin boyce's
twitter where a public school teacher
was decrying
the fact that covid means
that many of the conversations that
would have taken place inside the
classroom are now taking place
in a where you can't know whether family
members might be listening in
and that this is a threat to the social
justice work that this teacher
believes is essential and so really what
that means
is that there's so i didn't i didn't see
this but from what you just said
i can i can see what you just said
coming from a place of actual genuine
care as an educator
um this wasn't that okay but but let's
just let's just recognize that the idea
that
uh teenagers want may want to be able to
have conversations
with people they recognize as adults who
actually know something about the world
but not with their own
not within their own families is you
know that you know being able to talk to
your
uh religious leader you know that there
is a history of this that
is honorable yeah but no this is captive
audience
the point is you send your kid to school
and that puts you in the hand
puts the kid in the hands of somebody
who then has them
by law as a captive audience to
manipulate them and to tell them things
like some men have periods and stuff
like this
and the fact is it's unacceptable
and your family has the right to tell
you actually you know what i don't know
why people are insane
but people are now saying insane stuff
regularly and it is important that you
retain your ability to think in a world
people saying insane stuff
all the time yeah and the idea that this
is going to be exposed because you may
be on a zoom call rather than in a
classroom where you're going to be fed
the received wisdom
is it's just
um creating revealing the depth of
depravity that is unfolding in
in many schools yep okay
oh yeah we should switch over let me
just um two more quickly here
someone asks if we have a venmo that
they can donate to they don't take out
any money
uh and i suppose we could put a a venmo
link in the
in the description description yep
paypal also exists and paypal takes out
money though no
you don't if you use friends and family
they don't do it and the only reason not
to use friends and family is if you're
exchanging money for objects and you
want consumer protection stuff so
you can do it through paypal and uh it's
fee free
if you use the friends and family option
okay
we can we can also put a a venmo link
though
um and then um before we switch over
apparently kamala harris
has just been announced as biden's
vice president thoughts well i i
predicted that one
yeah um yeah this is so here's the thing
this
matters a ton because if you so i i
predict there are people he could have
picked
absent unity 2020 happening there are
people he could have picked
that maybe i could have become convinced
that because he cannot possibly last
four years
he was he was the right guy oh yeah if
if he had picked she's the opposite of
that
if he had picked andrew yang or tulsi
gabbard my thought would have been
well they're going to end up in the
presidency probably within the first
year
even elizabeth warren frankly who i used
to like a lot and like a lot less now
that she's gone
a bit woke but uh kamala harris
disaster um but you know look this is
just proof of the entire model's
accuracy which is
the dnc is the captor
of the democratic party it is about
influence peddling it
this is to the extent that we have an
obviously declining uh
and mentally compromised person
running at the top of the ticket it is
not
revealing that it is aware of that it is
uh going to put someone else
in the secondary position so that
uh it doesn't miss a beat with respect
to the policy proposals that
it finds um preferable
and you know we have no choice but to
revolt against this
the dnc is not your friend yeah
okay questions from this uh
this super chat did the advent of games
increase human additivity by providing
practice for the part of the brain that
contends with hypothetical situations
do populations with different games seem
to be differently adaptive to novelty
this is a great question um long ago
i was working on a project about
creativity and specifically about game
game and sport and unfortunately a lot
it doesn't leave a lot of record most
games that are played among at least
pre-agricultural people
are played with biodegradable stuff and
so don't leave a record as hard it's
hard to know
um but we have for instance talked about
what is the game called
llama among the maya um
who were before that maybe even the
olmec um
had some version of it right yep so i'm
going to say something about that
yeah the mesoamerican ball game the
llama is a very difficult game
it still exists you will see on temples
very frequently a ring a small ring
sticking sideways off of a building on
two
sides the court often has slanted sides
and
the idea was to get the ball through
it's like basketball but you know
but they're throwing right not no i
think really
well the modern game of ulama involves
like hitting it with your
hip it's a really difficult oh that's
right it's more like soccer yeah
yeah yeah um but anyway let's just say
in general these games have to pay back
and there's a lot of cost involved in
the case of ulama the cost
as we understand it involves either the
winners or the losers depends which
culture and at which moment in history
were put to death which is um you know
it's not
a lesson in perverse incentives at some
level
yeah it's a pretty a pretty interesting
game there's also um
uh some interesting stuff that unfolds
in
i believe it's borneo there are some
conflicts
you know where there's like an infinite
regress
of um
uh revenge and so the idea is that you
have to avenge the deaths
of people who were killed by the enemy
tribe
that's definitely the case in papua new
guinea maybe this is pop one again i'm
thinking about it or not
public is huge but in some of the tribes
right in papua new guinea
it's a highly diverse island but yeah in
any case
the point is you only count the last
death
and so the point is you're always you're
never even
because you're only counting the last
that's great
um but another place where we need a
little bit of math well
no i'm not so sure of that i'm wondering
if actually that the
that you know it's terribly wasteful but
that this is a mechanism for making sure
that
let's say that you just disengage and
you stop making war on your enemy
right your enemy could get really strong
while you're not paying attention and
the next time you make war they could
obliterate you
so what if you negotiated that you were
always
eliminating the last you're always
eventually the last death so you were
always dead even
always either on active offense or
active defense
right as a at a village level or a
population level right which would keep
two populations from ever getting out of
sync with each other i mean you know
this is a more general problem any i
don't know if that's
at all what's going on or even if i
necessarily have the setup correct but
the point is games are complex
they are expensive when you consider the
massive investment of time and energy
that is put into them
they persist over evolutionary time they
morph they're clearly adaptive so they
have to be paid for by some
some benefit that's even greater and
surely in many cases it has to do
with uh keeping your skills sharp for
warfare getting a team of people
to be able to understand what each other
are going to do on a battlefield
um so no doubt all of those games any
persistent game
is going to have an adaptive explanation
and the question is are they all the
same probably not
any of them are probably about war yeah
but uh no and the distinction
you know the the militant moderate here
who asked the question
specifies game not sport and um you know
sport obviously has element of game and
games is
as i as i have defined it basically
sport absent the physical
um so it is precisely potentially about
as the question asks providing practice
for the part of the brain that contends
with hypothetical situations
right and you know sport can deal with
hypotheticals as well but they have to
be you know perfectly staged and
choreographed whereas
um the kinds of games that don't involve
actual physical negotiation
um are abstract in the head yeah
next question did dark skin originally
evolve for antimicrobial protection
rather than uv protection
does it get shed excuse me does it get
shed when pathogens are less abundant
for instance when populations move away
from the tropics i heard trivers allude
to this
for instance in africa some very
dark-skinned ethnicities have
historically lived in the forest in
constant shade
thanks love you both so this from echo
uh i have this sort of fig glimmering
um of bob making this argument and i
have not gone
i i can't recall um
i mean i i trust that echo is reporting
accurately what he has
said and that he was accurate in
claiming
that within african populations some of
the most dark-skinned people are
actually understory dwellers
which would seem to suggest that there
is at least some other benefit
uh to dark skin rather than uv
protection
yeah um there was a lot of contingencies
though
yeah i have my my doubts about this and
so you have to
yes melanin has a cost to produce um
so to the extent that that cost is not
being paid back you would expect it to
be
quickly reduced on the other hand it may
be
you know how long have these populations
that live in the understory
lived that way and is the benefit
do they spend 100 of their time in the
understory
is the benefit if they you know cross
between patches of forest and they're
exposed to intense sunlight for
you know a small number of days a year
would that justify the maintenance
because the real question is the
avoidance of damage
don't know i think the fact that dark
skin is often
lightened in populations that have moved
away
from africa in particular is probably
the result
of interbreeding um more than anything
else
but i don't know what i don't know
is the microbial uh
question it's not obvious yeah so it's
an alternative uh
alternative hypothesis for the benefit
but there's a
there's an implied mechanism there that
isn't spelled out sufficiently for us to
assess right yeah did it evolve from
antimicrobial protection
yeah i'm just trying to imagine how that
would work is it
just simply a thermal question
that because it's black it heats up
faster and it would
create an extreme environment is there
something about a topical fever
yeah yeah yeah okay
it's a hypothesis anyway it's it's an
hypothetical it's an
hypothesis cova decide what is a model
which we can improve our current
education system do you foresee ways of
receiving accreditation outside of
universities in the future
i love you too thanks um it's a big
question
you know i i i was i should
i should dredge it up but i saw today uh
one of the most amazing rube goldberg
mechanisms i've ever seen it was made
out of stuff that was clearly
you know sourced at goodwill or
something it wasn't like
a really refined one but it was
elaborate it went all the way around
this entire house and down into a forest
and
um anyway it was amazing and i was
thinking to myself
how smart would you end up if this is
what you did
instead of school you know because
basically there were you know dozens of
different mechanisms for getting things
to trigger other things
and you would learn a tremendous amount
and there are of course things that you
would not learn that way that you would
want to supplement with maybe some other
game
but the point is you know i don't know
whether we can rescue the system of
education it's so
targeted at the wrong thing it's really
not built to make you smarter
and there are lots of things that do
make you smarter and the question is can
we
uh find people who are capable of i
don't even want to say teaching because
it may not be teaching
but capable of facilitating learning and
teaching aren't
the same thing they have they should
have considerable overlap
but what you want is children
and then adults who are know how to
teach themselves
and who are excited about doing so right
and that's not even two
things it's like look you know
here's an object you would like to
produce here are the tools with which it
is produced
here are some instructions on how to use
those tools
do you have what it takes to get from
the tools and the raw materials to the
object that you want to have produced
now it's exposing exposing children to
problems
uh that they might or might not yet have
the facility
and tools to solve across a wide variety
of domains you know physical domains
out out in the woods inside in
labs with words with math
all of these different domains many of
which have been just excluded from
school with
music with sport all of these things you
know the
things like sport are often mocked
for being in education at all and then
you know of course as soon as sports got
sort of demoted then we started seeing
recess cut so now we've got this just
sort of brands and jars model now
we need fully embodied kids who are
excited to actually engage with whatever
it is that is being done
and same thing when you know arts
programs are being cut well you know
is art as important as you know they
learn to read
i don't know every kid needs to learn
how to read but um do they really
need to learn how to spell at this point
is that more important than
being with you know their classmates
making music
every now and again or regularly i don't
think so
well you know at the point you get to
their classes i just think
the model is broken at the reason that
you should do
x is because we told you to and it will
be bad for you not to and it'll be good
for you to do it
yeah it's just a lousy motivational
structure
and there are lots of good motivational
structures where somebody actually feels
good about accomplishing something
for some reason other than you know the
teacher
patted him on the head yeah hey buddy
all right
um i was delightfully surprised to find
george gammon
is a fan of yours you know who that is
no economic collapse is what he focuses
on hit him up
he would be you would be a good guest on
his rebel capitalist show
rebel capitalist it's cool does he
create economic collapses
or in my opinion covid social unrest and
recession
will converge this winter yeah yeah
that's i think unfortunately not too
risky a prediction
covid economic collapse and so uh
covid social unrest and recession uh
yeah and uh psychosis
no oh boy
uh let's what time is it zack how how
long have we been here
105. let's do three more how about that
all right uh
now let's do four more cause i like the
fourth one in line
uh great show what do you both think
about jonathan heights claim
that 2015 marked the turning point for
campus protests
was that your experience
so he his sort of two-pronged claim
as i remember it was that along with
greg lukianov was that 2013 or so
is when people started to see uh
the beginnings of the unraveling of the
population of people on campus and
people were beginning to ask for trigger
warnings
and safe spaces and things like that and
then 2015
is when uh the protests you know campus
much like apparently portland is a
protest city campuses are always protest
places like protests will happen on
campuses every now and again
um but that the nature of them changed
around 2015
and you know i think anecdotally that's
a that's a match for us but i think more
interesting is sort of tracking back
like what what all was in place and you
know and we've i've used this language
of a perfect storm
a lot um but you know broken k-12
schooling
helicopter and snow plow parenting
giving legal drugs to kids to basically
um mute their moods and
make sure that they don't know how to be
adults and putting them in screens all
day long
well of course they get to college and
they are unregulated and incompetent
of course they are yeah it's it's hard
to know for one thing
um we only had access to one college
directly
yeah and what we saw was very atypical
because of
our very vibrant and um
non-crazy community which was composed
of a bunch of stars
our particular students because
obviously there were parts of the
evergreen community that were
quite crazy clearly and there were
clearly things being taught in
some quadrants of the campus uh that
were
nonsense and metastasized yeah worse
than nonsense
uh pernicious yeah malignant nonsense um
so it's a little hard to say but uh i
think he
uh he and lukiana for in the ballpark
with respect to the tipping point yeah
absolutely many youtubers generate
income from live in-person events with
fans such as golf tournaments etc
have you considered leading a hike for
patrons who donate significantly or
something similar
yeah we have we've talked about leading
what we were calling evolution weekends
in and around portland uh and we've also
talked about leading
uh trips farther afield to places like
tippatini
in the ecuador and amazon um you know
maybe maybe at some point it can be very
stimulating to have a discussion about
evolution while looking at monkeys
yes yes especially if they are squirrel
monkeys or marmosets
or td monkeys or okay all of them don't
mean night monkeys
yeah heller monkey's not as interesting
yeah but they'll do
but yeah um it's so
weird to me that we have a cat right in
front of us and that they can't see the
cat
oh no you know they can see his ear yeah
what's up
a little bit on screen yeah okay two
more questions for today uh
i have a theory that mask wearing is
more accepted in asian countries
partly because they look for emotions in
the eyes
what do you think i think we all look
for emotions in the eyes
don't we do you so the the question i
think presumes
that asian cultures are more prone to be
looking for emotion in the eyes
and you know maybe maybe
therefore that they are less likely to
show emotion than the rest of their face
such that covering the rest of the face
is less of a hit
sort of emotionally and cognitively for
communication
well all it has to be is more
in order for this to make sense um but
it raises a deeper question
let's say for example or uh for the sake
of argument that
this is correct and that asians
typically
uh do read more emotion in the eyes is
that because there's something about
asians that is genomically prone to this
or is that because
emotionality is conveyed in the eyes and
therefore
in the same way that we don't have a
tonal language and have a hard time
learning one
do they learn to convey emotions with
the eyes in ways that people from
cultures that don't do this don't learn
and therefore
uh they are predisposed
i guess what i would say so it's causing
it you're saying if if there's a
correlation
you might you might uh your default
assumption would be the cause and effect
of reversed from
what the question is supposing well i
wouldn't say cause and effect reversed i
would say
maybe there's some arbitrary reason
emotion gets conveyed in every culture
it may be conveyed on different channels
it may be that asian cultures convey it
more in the eyes i don't know if that's
true but let's say it was
and then covid comes along and it just
interfaces with this arbitrarily
cover your mouth cover your mouth and
your nose we could do that yeah yeah
um then uh
it would be less disruptive so anyway
it's plausible
but i'd be i'd be really curious a
whether the claim is right and
the observation has to be true and then
we can talk about whether or not the
hypothesis that would explain the
observation
might be true yeah yeah final question
do you have do you have advice on how
women can stay safe while traveling
do you ever find yourself holding back
from adventures because it would be
unsafe for a woman
so this is there's there's a lot to be
said here
and um you know i have enjoyed traveling
alone
a lot and it is risky and you do take on
risk by doing so
but you also end up in situations that
are good
that you cannot end up in if you are
are with someone so
holding back on adventures because would
be unsafe i'm sure i've made those
decisions i mean i think you'd be
you'd be a fool to not recognize um that
you know as as a woman traveling alone
there are particular risks
um that you are taking that are unlike
the risks that you would be taking if
you were a man traveling alone
and so you have to make different
decisions sometimes but um
you know we've i was gonna i guess the
story i was just about to
tell hasn't been told publicly so i'm
not gonna say it yet we've written it
into the book so i'm not going to
share that one here we've definitely
when we've been traveling together
we have run into situations where i was
incredibly grateful that we were
together and that i wasn't alone but i
i always have to wonder what would i
have done differently in the run-up
you know i have been that combination of
lucky and smart
and i have i have not i have not been
hurt um
in any of these situations in any in any
real way
but it doesn't you can't just be smart
and you certainly can't just be lucky
because you can't depend on luck and so
there is no guarantee
but you do have to decide in advance
what your tolerance
is and also get a real sense of what the
background culture
is um you know for instance it was
advised when we started working in latin
america and
a couple of seasons we were in different
parts of latin america we were both down
there at the same time we were in
different countries sometimes
um when we were in grad school you know
with the this is before we were married
that's oh you know
you know women should wear a wedding
band whether or not they're married like
just you know because it helps
it helps fend off unwanted attention
well that fends off unwanted attention
exactly as long as the person can ask
the question well he's not here is he so
you need a boyfriend right
so it does it doesn't actually work like
none of these simple signals
actually do the trick um you have to be
prepared
actively to defend yourself and to move
out of a cond
out of a situation if if it's not if
it's not safe and you i did have to
change where
i was actually based um a couple of
times when i was doing field work alone
in costa rica um because um the
the dude who owned the place where i was
staying proved not to be trustworthy
and like i said i never got hurt never
got hands on me but it could have well
ended up differently if i had not
taken the sort of spidey sense i was
getting and then
some some more clear indicators
seriously so um
it's going to be context specific but
the idea that um
you know not you know being gender
non-conforming and being sort of you
know a badass and
carrying a machete around like that's
not sufficient you know if you're a
woman it's just different you just have
different risks
than if you're a man with all risk it is
important um that you
we have a thing shorthand is the theory
of close calls
which is as you engage in something
dangerous
things tend to go wrong slightly before
they go severely wrong and if you regard
the fact that they didn't go
catastrophically wrong as evidence that
you're doing something right you will
end up with them ultimately going
catastrophically wrong
and if you take the data that comes from
the
near misses and things as evidence of
what you might change then you can
actually
discover where the hazards are and how
to avoid them so yeah it's that's
interesting that you raised that here
because
we've obviously we've talked about that
a lot we've talked about with our kids a
lot this theory of close calls
and i've always thought of it with
regard to the abiotic stuff
right with regard to the the waves and
the tree falls
and the rising water and the rivers and
you know these these things that happen
and
respond in no way depending on how you
respond to them right like they don't
they don't change their behavior because
you were
fierce or careful or smart or whatever
you just have to have been
out of the way or be able to get out of
the way as it happens
in a social situation is different
right um and uh
you can learn the sort of categories of
people you know the vast majority of um
you know walking down a street in some
latin american capital
and getting a lot of attention from men
the vast majority of them have no
intention of doing anything more than
that how do you figure out
who the tiny percentage of people who
would and making sure that you never end
up alone
um in a dark alley with such people um
it's it doesn't necessarily track you
that lesson doesn't necessarily track to
if you're in egypt or if you're you know
if you're in some other place in the
world with very different cultural norms
around behavior between the sexes those
are two different things though
i agree that the lessons of latin
america won't necessarily
translate to the middle east but um
the theory of close calls still works
you know and you can even detect
you know there may be parts of town
where you're not
safe and you don't know them and the
fact that the
rate of attention that you get as you
move in this direction goes up
is one of these things where you will
attack you will be uncomfortable before
you're in danger
so it's not to say that you know you can
always encounter the thing that'll
kill you on the first go just out of
sheer bad luck but that's not how it
tends to work
you do tend to get indicators before you
get the thing
that's crippling and well and this
actually maybe this is this is part of
it i mean i assume the way that this
question is asked and the fact that
they're asking in this live stream i
assume that they already know this but
one of the things that is so
actually crippling about much of the
modern discourse around like safe spaces
and such
is this assumption that um the idea that
women are more at risk if they're
scantily clad
walking alone late at night is an
outrage
and we object to that right and like you
know what that is
that is just true and i'm not justifying
the fact you know
you said when we were on rogan together
a couple years ago right like
sure it would be great if you could ride
naked down you know down the street
um as a woman but you can't that's
that's that's not the world we live in
it's not that it would be great we
should live in a world so
safe that you're walking through the
center of town
lathered up in oil and uh you know
and naked is not taken as consent by
anybody right but you'd be a fool to do
it you'd be a fool to do it
and excuse me
um recognizing
keeping keeping hyper aware of your
surroundings being
very aware of how you are presenting
and how where you are and of all of the
people around you
and obviously that's different if you're
in a public place that you know where
there's a lot of you know at
a club for instance versus walking away
from the club back home
on streets that are increasingly
deserted but it's neighborhoods you know
and therefore you have some sense of it
versus leaving such a place in a city
that you're visiting you don't really
know and you're just going back to an
airbnb or a hotel these are three very
different situations and in each case
what you need to do is have a model of
how the world responds to you especially
in
the scene in which you're in you know
how you're dressed and how you are
presenting and what time of night it is
whether or not you have any friends with
you and
not being outraged the fact that the
world may do something horrifying to you
even though that is awful but actually
taking as much responsibility as you can
to make sure that you reduce the chances
that something horrible happens to you
and that
is not in any way victim blaming it is
saying
okay now you're taking as much
responsibility as you possibly can
for the un for the inequitable outcomes
in the world
that result from being a woman versus
being a man wandering alone
you know late at night or in some just
deserted place because you traveled
somewhere alone
it actually strikes me that it is the
perfect analog
for the general conflict between
the personal responsibility side which
conservatives tend to see and the
collective
responsibility side which liberals tend
to see which is
let's say for example that you turn out
to be a woman
as i did yes quite and for this i am
grateful as well but
you're a woman you
[Music]
face two things one is the question of
how you will
walk through the world and the other is
whether the world
requires things of you that it shouldn't
right should you be safe
in any city in the world dressed however
you feel like being dressed
at all times of day and night yes
we should want that world right but you
don't live in that world so should you
say well it's not my responsibility to
make me safe society
should make me safe we all agree to that
so therefore i'm going to address
however i will dress i'm going to ignore
what time of day it is what part of town
i'm in etc etc
and if something happens that's
civilization's fault well
no the point is let's say that you
invest
in the societal responsibility side how
much are you likely to make yourself
safer
almost none so if you say well anything
you say about how i might be dressed in
what part of town and all that
is you victim blaming then you are
making yourself
uh vulnerable whereas if you invested
entirely
in the personal responsibility side you
have a huge impact on how much danger
you're in
and so the point is both things are true
yeah right both things are true
no i yeah i have maybe this is the place
to end
this is an anecdote but i have this
memory uh from
uh from college i was i was briefly at
one of the seven sisters i was at smith
which is a women's college um clustered
in with a bunch of other colleges
for those who know um northampton
massachusetts amherst is there and umass
amherst and
mount holyoke new hampshire they're all
close together and so even though two of
those colleges are women's colleges on
friday and saturday nights
there is a lot of interchange between
them and so um
i remember coming back from a friend's
house
um and you know i didn't i didn't wear
heels then i don't like i
i don't and so yes i did have a judgment
about seeing all of these smith women
who were so vocal about their
feminist um feelings and then
dolling themselves up and teetering
around in heels which are inherently
um you know not good shoes
to be in if you feel that you might be
in any danger you might need to escape
from something
and you know coming back i lived on
campus the very very brief moment that i
went to this school
um and i could see you across campus in
this beautifully sculpted land the
landscaped campus
uh this woman who clearly had been
drinking too just her silhouette
she's in heel she's staggering she's
almost falling down and you can because
she's just in silhouette with the lights
well-lit campus in order to keep people
safe and all this but
you know super well lit in silhouette
in heels falling down drunk alone
late at night on a friday or saturday
night and i could it was she was across
a pond for me i couldn't get to her my
mind my inclination was like i should
just go be with this woman even though
i'm a woman too but i'm not dressed like
that and i'm not drunk and i could
potentially
help her get wherever she's going and i
did end up like
seeing her get into a building but my
thought was for god's sake like
this is what friends are for for one
thing like she never should have been
alone in that situation
but god forbid something had happened to
her
no nothing ever should have happened to
her but the combination of being
alone at night drunk in shoes that would
never have allowed her to make a fast
getaway
all would have contributed to the fact
that she would have been hurt and i'm
so grateful that i didn't see this woman
get hurt but that scene is just
emblazoned in my memory as like that is
someone who is not taking the kind of
care of herself
as she should be and so like that's
that's what you don't do
when you're traveling right that's you
know you
you just don't put yourself in that
situation yeah if you just simply
imagine
um predators exist and there's nothing
we can do
to eliminate them 100 we should do
better than we do but
they're going to be predatory men and
you don't want to be
uh you know the
the deer with the limp exactly because
the predator is looking for the
vulnerable individual so
you know allowing yourself to be that is
uh
i hesitate to use the word inviting
catastrophe
but uh you know that's not victim
blaming the point is it's common sense
yeah all right well thank you for that
question thank you for all of these
questions they are as usual
really really good we appreciate
the support we invite you to go to
either of our patreons to get more
content
uh the clips channel dark horse clips
channel go to
what is the url for uh unity 2020 uh the
unity 2020
url is articles of unity.org
and again we're going to have a campfire
tomorrow afternoon
four o'clock boyer and
john wood jr yeah four o'clock pacific
time
so join us for that and uh anything else
no we'll probably probably be back in a
week maybe sooner
all right be well everyone